oficina de aduana y seguridad fronteriza
en eeuu registraron un máximo histórico
en los últimos 20 años y tan sólo en el
mes de marzo de 19 mil menores que
cruzaron precisamente hacia eeuu no
acompañados una cifra que duplica sin
duda lo acontecido en los meses
anteriores de este 2021 en medio de un
panorama y de una crisis que se
recrudecen migratorio en los eeuu y
medio también del anuncio del presidente
joe biden de que dará protección a estos
menores que son víctimas de estos
movimientos muchas veces forzados de
estas movilizaciones y bueno en medio de
ese panorama en méxico también hay
cifras el boletín informativo mensual de
unicef dio a conocer que cerca de 1.000
menores en las últimas semanas fueron
repatriados de estados unidos hacia
méxico estamos hablando de menores
mexicanos de estos mil cerca de 850 no
venían acompañados precisamente pues
para dar una mayor atención y
preocupados por este sector de la
infancia desprotegido que no se ha
habilitado un albergue más en la ciudad
de tijuana este centro de primera
acogida para niños y
y no acompañados y donde podrán
permanecer hasta 45 días hasta que no se
encuentren algún familiar con quien
puedan ser transferidos o bien sean de
una vez también enviados a otro albergue
de la iniciativa privada pero ya será el
gobierno de la autoridad municipal aquí
de tijuana quien tome cartas en el
asunto un albergue que opera
precisamente bajo los lineamientos
también del gobierno de la ciudad de
tijuana y de unicef este organismo que
tiene presencia activa en varios países
y que plasma en un documento de más de
40 páginas el por qué deben de existir
estos sitios para darle una mayor
protección a esta niñez que está en
desventaja y en riesgo de morir en
cualquier instante